and nabi finally the question on europe
i think there's a very interesting
question this and Anna I don't I don't
notice a reaction in favor of sort of
you know greater Christianity if you
like yet but I emphasize yet and mainly
what this this this which is pretty much
it's pretty much a concern about Islam I
mean once you know it's not concerned
about all religions so you've got this
minaret issue in Switzerland they she's
new in France of the burger and so on
the guy willders in Holland and so forth
now at the moment the reaction is more
to do i would say it kind of congregates
more round an issue immigration but it's
an interesting point as to whether it it
will start to produce a religious
dimension very specifically and i think
it's possible actually and one of the
things I've noticed rather worryingly
actually is that some Christian
denominations in fact I think you can
say this to an extent about the Catholic
Church actually have become rather more
anxious about interfaith because they
kind of feel that position of compromise
or weakness when they feel a very
forceful Islamist ISM that they see in
certain parts coming at them and it's an
interesting thing this to see how it it
plays out
because you know what as I say what what
what this this pastor jones thing over
here does but you can see this in in in
the UK as well over certain issues is
that what people start to think is and
how to put this through diplomatic lee i
mean i'm a is impossible to because it's
not really a diplomatic sentiment that
people feel about it but I tell you just
that with this this this pastor guy here
there will be at the same time as the
whole of Orthodox opinion is out there
condemning him there will be a segment
and I can just kind of feel this because
you get these intuitions there's a
politician who will kind of say why
we're having to make all the fuss about
it and that will translate into a you
know bit of a backlash against the
backlash if you see what I mean and I
think that the in a lot of the parts of
Europe at the moment I mean I used to
get because I spend obviously we had the
bombings in in in London I used to spend
a lot of time with the Islamic community
and I used to run into real problems
with the Hindu community would say
you're spending all your time were those
guys just cuz they're crazy people go
around blowing people up you know so
does that now whether that ever
translates you know into as a religious
revival almost I don't know but I think
one thing is for sure that we're playing
with very very raw and uncontrollable
forces here and it is a remarkable thing
just the degree to which these things
can you know suck in the political
energy across countries at the present
time